I just was terrified I'm just gonna be
this eight-year-old the [ __ ] stamp
whatever you know this could be really
really stupid
I absolutely hate it I hate it hi my
name is Ken and I'm gonna tell you about
my tattoo horror story so I'm a huge
Spice Girl fan favorite Spice Girl as
Posh Spice Victoria Beckham is amazing I
decided to go to a tattoo parlor for
their $30 tattoo day and get a cheap
tattoo I have never done that before and
I was like why not and I go in and they
have an easel with all their tattoos
that they're offering for $30 I didn't
see anything that I liked nothing was a
spice girl there's there's nothing cool
except for letters and I was like all
right I'm gonna get posh written on my
wrists I went and I paid for it went
back in line and they I think they had
to tattoo artists that were doing it and
it was just like this mechanical thing
like people were just going in out in
out probably should have been like maybe
I should come back on another day but
nope I wanted this Ted they're $30
tattoo best thing ever so finally after
maybe gone a couple hours of waiting my
turn this guy was not pleasant at all he
just looked miserable I understand
you're tattooing people all day but I'm
like this is my body don't do that I was
trying to be extra friendly and I'm like
hi and he is this like and then he takes
out the razor to cut my arm hair off my
underarm does not have that much on
there he just started kind of just
picking away with the razor and blood
was everywhere and I'm just sitting
there like he gets the temporary tattoo
which he puts on first is to show me and
it was a little bit bigger than I wanted
I was really scared to be like this
isn't what I wanted because he looked
like hell like he was not having it so I
was like okay we're here
I'm bleeding let's get this over with
I let him just do what he wanted 45
minutes later he was done during the
process he was wiping every once in a
while and he wasn't wiping like ink or
like the blood from his tattooing it was
the blood from the cuts that he made on
my wrist with a razor I just was
terrified with a smile because I don't
know what to do he put on the clear
plastic you know bandage around my arm
after I was done I looked at it and it
looked like it was like like a rain
blood on my arm I walked out never went
back there again and I don't think I'm
ever gonna get a cheap tattoo ever again
it's not what I wanted it does not speak
posh it doesn't look like something
Victoria Beckham was like if she saw it
on me she'd be like I like it because
it's part of it let's leave it at that
hi I'm Ferren and today I'm gonna be
telling you about my tattoo Horror Story
I got my first tattoo when I was like 21
or 22 ish it was true what they say like
once you get your first one you're sort
of addicted I got my next one probably
like six months after that and then I
got my next one probably like a year
after that and then I got my next one
like six months after that I was with my
girlfriend for like maybe a year or so
and she was really into stars one day we
were walking around and she was like we
should get tattoos today and so I was
like okay that's fine you know I'm
addicted now I've gotten one so now I'm
like a big deal so like I can get
another one we went into the tattoo shop
and she found the one that she wanted
and then I was like I'm not really
feeling any of these but I was like I'm
just gonna do it cuz I love her and then
I stumbled upon the one that I have now
like one big star and then like five
little stars like around it why I chose
that I don't know next thing to do was
to choose where I'm gonna put it and of
course at like 21 22 you're like where's
the best place to put a tattoo I know my
lower back then tat insult to injury the
tattoo shop that we went to was sort of
sketch so they did a really really
terrible job and so now any time you rub
your fingers over it or your hand over
it you can feel it so like I'm reminded
this day of my life that I wish I could
take back by this like Braille tattoo
that I have them on my back right now
that probably says like you're dumb and
Braille imagine every single time you
like wear bathing suit or you know your
meanness in my room you know they're
asking you like what is this tattoo on
your back and every single tattoo that
you have has a really great meaning and
story except for this [ __ ] stamp I have
thought about getting it removed but it
just seems like such a big like waste of
money and time and I've dealt with it
this long I can deal with it a little
bit longer I'm just gonna be this
eight-year-old the [ __ ] stamp and I
can't stop saying transient cuz that's
what it is hello my name is Merle and
today I'm going to be telling you about
my tattoo horror story journey back with
me I was traveling with one of my very
best friend Steven we had just had a
wonderful New Year's Eve in a coma see
tomorrow at this teeny isolated little
fishing town in Thailand and then a
hurricane came through and almost ruined
the rest of our trip we had flown to
this other part of Thailand and the
plane almost crashed they wanted to get
a stick and poke tattoo and I'm like I'm
gonna live life on the edge gonna get a
teeny teeny teeny teeny little v on the
inside of my elbow because v is my
number we had heard through another
friend who was living in Thailand that
this place was legit this tattoo parlor
was at a bar bar might be a stretch a
shack with a corner with pillows on it a
bar that sold joints then there was a
back-alley area where you can get
tattoos the place did not look clean I'm
not gonna lie to you it didn't look good
I'm introduced to the man who is going
to be the one performing what do you
even call it not surgery the the do and
the thing he's this little man with wild
hair his eyes are like this wide I know
he was on something but he was taking it
very very seriously he's like are you
ready I'm not sure he takes out the
needle there's no certificate on the
wall to for cleanliness there's no
promise that this whatever you know
this could be really really stupid
there's a woman who's running topless
behind me these are the sounds and
sights that are around me as I'm about
to get my first tattoo in Thailand I was
tested later totally fine no no problems
I'm good we're good the way I did it
probably wasn't the smartest but it has
a happy ending I love my tattoo so is it
a horror story let's call it a near
horror story if my mom knew how this
happened she would be horrified so yeah
that's how I got my first and only
tattoo hi I'm Elena and today I will be
telling you about my tattoo Horror Story
I only have two tattoos currently I will
get more but the second tattoo I got I
was like oh god I'm not sure I'll ever
get another tattoo again I think with
tattoos you always have the thing that's
in your head and then the thing that
ends up being on your body is slightly
different probably than what you had in
your head but like that being said like
a lot of artists get close like
especially if you're like working with
the artists I had this idea in my head
that I wanted to get a tattoo with my
pets on it I have a bunny named empanada
who was just an absolute legend and I
have this kitten named taquito I wanted
to get kind of like a yin and yang
almost where their bodies kind of like
fit into each other and I finally found
the perfect human and I thought oh my
god like I love every single thing she
makes like there's no way she can mess
this up we booked the appointment I had
sent her an email with like a bunch of
pictures and videos of my pets because I
wanted her to like be able to see them
and like get their personalities and
their likeness she's like no worries
thanks for sending all those things I'll
just be in the back drawing for like the
next 20 to 30 minutes and then I'll come
out and you know we'll get going an hour
goes by and she is not back from drawing
and then an hour and a half goes by I
mean while getting very nervous like why
is it taking so long and then she comes
out with a sketch and I absolutely hate
it I
I'm starting to make these like very
panic like calls of like well maybe we
just changed like this little detail or
we start trying to change this but you
know I didn't know how to say no I
didn't know how to be like I don't like
this she like went to the back to like
redo the parts that we had you know
talked about redoing and meanwhile I'm
having like a low-key panic attack and
at this point I realized this tattoo is
gonna cost like several hundred dollars
more than I had originally thought it
was going to so I'm just like oh my god
I'm about to make a very expensive
mistake I didn't want to like upset her
or make her mad at me or disappointed
and that's very very silly because this
is like a stranger who I will never see
you again she comes back out with this
second sketch and I still don't love it
but at this point I'm exhausted
it's been like two and a half hours and
I'm just like okay it's fine it's fine
just like put it on me I'm done like I'm
done being able to like feel anything
about this just like put it on me and so
she did because I told her to I would
have rather like not disappointed a
complete stranger than let them put
something on my body that will
absolutely not go away unless I remove
it with like lasers and she I wish I had
made a lot of different choices it's not
a contract you've already signed once
you walked in the door
find diplomatic ways to be like let's
pause I need to think about it like as
you continue to change you can continue
to play with like how you're expressing
yourself visually on your body
[Music]
you